[Music]
everybody is Charlie you may have heard
the news about a Super Mario Brothers
movie coming from Nintendo in a company
called illumination entertainment there
are a bunch of other Nintendo movie and
TV projects that have been rumored in
the last couple of weeks so I'll try to
do a breakdown of everything if you're a
brand new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get videos I don't do a ton
of video game related stuff on my main
channel here because it's mostly movies
TV shows stuff like that
I do have separate video game channels
like I have a twitch channel and I have
a separate YouTube channel just for
video games stuff the links for those
are down in the description but this new
Super Mario Brothers movie the rumored
Netflix Legend of Zelda series that's
like the intersection of everything that
I do in video games so it's a really
cool opportunity that I'm really excited
about if everything pans out the way we
hope it will so I'll explain where all
these projects are at starting with the
Super Mario Brothers movie most of you
if you've been around long enough you're
at least a little bit familiar with or
you've seen the original Super Mario
Brothers movie it is an endurance test
that every fan needs to put themselves
on at some point in their lives it is
the worst movie ever but you just have
to watch it because it is literally the
only Super Mario Brothers movie that we
have right now so hopefully this new
project will wipe everyone's minds the
original movie came at a time when
Nintendo was trying to expand his
footprint in Hollywood it had all this
really awesome IP that fans loved all
over the world so I was just looking for
other opportunities outside of just
straight-up video games you have a bunch
of really popular characters naturally
the inclination is to try and turn that
into a movie or a TV series so the movie
came in when it was a disaster and ever
since then Nintendo has been famously
conservative with is IP never again you
can see them a shaking their fists in
the distance you can't blame them for
that either after watching that movie
but what happened is around 2014
everyone's hunting for big franchises at
all the big studios because those are
the things that really earn money so
after being courted by a number of big
studios it started talking to Sony about
doing more movies based on Nintendo IP
and naturally the first place they would
go was their most popular characters
which would be Super Mario Brothers
we never really
found out what happened in those early
talks but eventually what happened is as
Miyamoto came onto the project and he
started working with a person called
Chris Melander II through Nintendo's
relationship at Universal Parks and
studios so no surprise Nintendo's trying
to create theme parks based on its IP
like imagine Disneyland but with
Nintendo characters seems like an easy
slam-dunk for them but because Universal
is owned by Comcast which also owns
DreamWorks and DreamWorks Animation that
sort of got Nintendo in bed with the
people at DreamWorks
that's why recently they announced the
Super Mario Brothers movie is coming
from illumination entertainment which is
associated with DreamWorks Animation
through the studio that's known for
doing the despicable Me movies and the
minions movies which you're either
indifferent about or outright terrified
at the idea of them getting their hands
on Nintendo IP like what is a Super
Mario Brothers movie going to look like
if it's inside this world of animation
or are they gonna change their animation
style because have you been seeing all
the trailers for spider-man into the
spider-verse Sony animation is doing
that they actually tried to push the
limits of what they could do making it
look like a comic book and mixing in a
lot of 2d and 3d styles so there's a lot
of questions about what the visual style
is going to be in on another level one
of the big problems with the Super Mario
Brothers franchise in adapting it to
movies or TV is that it doesn't really
have like an overarching story in the
way that Legend of Zelda does or the
Metroid series you have this loose story
of Bowser trying to take over the
kingdom and Mario trying to stop him but
that's about all you have like there
have been other stories that have tried
to build that out a little bit more
there's been the Super Mario RPG games
but all the rumors recently about the
story for this new movie is that it's
gonna be something original with the
loose relationships being intact like
obviously Bowser would be the villain of
the film peach Mario Luigi would be the
heroes but beyond that it doesn't seem
like they're gonna be rehashing the
story or the loose story of any of the
classic games or the newer ones moving
into slightly more promising things you
may have also heard about the newer
rumors about a Netflix Legend of Zelda
series we heard about that a while ago
when they were ramping up to release
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
amazing game great story so just a much
easier task of adapting it to TV or
movies the reason why everyone has been
saying TV series is
because Adi Shankar one of the producers
on Netflix's Castlevania series
obviously a video game adaptation that's
gone really well it's an amazing series
has said that he's been in talks with a
major video game studio about adapting a
huge fan favorite franchise and because
he's mostly known recently for doing
animated projects websites have been
reporting that it is a Legend of Zelda
series but Nintendo is like I said
famously conservative with its IP and
doesn't release a lot of information
like that ahead of time so I wouldn't
expect any really big news about that
anytime soon what they might do is wait
till III next summer to make any
definitive announcements about whether
or not that's moving forward what
they've been trying to do recently with
the Nintendo switch is get more video
content on it because right now people
have just been using it as a video game
console but you can actually use it as a
streaming device too recently they just
announced that we're gonna put a YouTube
app on it so there just hasn't been
access to a ton of video content yet but
you have all these people running around
with what's essentially a really small
tablet which is great for watching stuff
on so of course Nintendo would try to
make other kinds of content for that so
a Legend of Zelda series would just be
the next step but the way the CEO of
Nintendo talks they're starting with
their biggest most popular characters
first when it comes to these kinds of
projects which is why a lot of these
other Nintendo movie and TV shows people
have been talking about like the metroid
movie you've been hearing a lot of noise
about the past couple of days depend on
the success of this Mario movie so if
the animated Super Mario Brothers movie
does well then yeah you'll definitely
see them try other stuff but if it does
poorly you probably won't hear about
another Nintendo movie for a long time
the rumor about the Metroid movies
started after brie Larson Captain Marvel
dressed up as Samus Aran for Halloween
and answered this person on Twitter
saying you know this is the closest
we're ever gonna get to a Metroid movie
and she's like hell no I really hope to
make that movie someday so all that
means is that she's a really big fan of
that character and thinks it would be
cool to make a movie like that so they
haven't announced any kind of official
plans to make a Metroid movie but you
can bet that her agents after that
exchange were on the phone with Nintendo
and the studio's trying to pitch a
Metroid movie but like I said Nintendo
famously conservative with its IP so
just because
like an actor looks kind of like a
character and says that they want to do
it in there blowing up right now and
really popular doesn't mean Nintendo is
gonna throw open the doors and say do
whatever you want with our characters I
mean if they do end up making a Metroid
movie it will take years of development
and just like Legend of Zelda probably
works better as a longer format TV
series I would say the same as true of
Metroid just because that universe is so
big so I would much rather see them try
that as an animated series long format
that try to do a live-action two-hour
movie because if brie Larson were gonna
star in it then they would do it
live-action so you could see her face
otherwise there'd be no point in casting
her they could put anybody they want to
underneath that mask which raises other
problems too because one of the
hallmarks of the Samus Iran character is
that she never takes her helmet off so
that also raises questions like why
would you cast a big-name actor if you
could put anybody underneath the helmet
there's a lot of problems be solved let
me know in the comments which Nintendo
movie or TV show are you most excited
about what'll happen is there's a whole
bunch of marvel and DC stuff that was
announced recently so I'll try to do
videos for that as quick as possible
click here for that new Captain Marvel
teaser and click here for a brand new
flash reverse flash deleted scene thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you